When we are machine knitting,
the whole purpose of the yarn mass is
to keep steady,
even tension on your working yarn.
But things can go wrong.
If you hit a knot or the yarn gets caught
up somehow,
maybe it gets caught up under the cone.
You might have a few stitches
that are misformed and way too tight.
The only remedy for this is to rip
out to this row and start again.
Sometimes after you've ripped or you've
done some hand manipulation or changed
colors or for whatever reason,
the mast isn't engaged in putting
the proper tension on your working yarn.
My first knitting teacher
taught me to milk the cow.
Hold down on the yarn behind the tension
mast and make sure that the mast engages,
and it will ensure perfectly
formed stitches every time.
It's a good habit to check.
Any time you start knitting,
you first sit down to knit or you've
gotten up to take a break,
make sure that tension mast is engaged
and you've got nicely formed stitches.